75 days after being picked to lead the
response to the border crisis vice
president kamala harris is on her first
foreign trip in guatemala today
harris says stopping migration is a top
priority but she is already at odds with
that country's president
over what is actually causing the
problem the vp also saying she will not
be visiting the southern border because
she is focused on results instead of
quote grand
gestures and as the administration
struggles to stop an influx of migrants
harris has this message i want to be
clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making
that dangerous trek to the united states
mexico border
do not come do not come
we as one of our priorities will
discourage
illegal migration
and i believe if you come to our border
you will be turned back
but guatemala's president is blaming
president biden's messaging for
the record search changed too
we're going to reunite families and
we're going to reunite children
the very next day the coyotes are here
organizing groups of children to take
them to the united states
all right here we go greg so what did
you think of her comments especially
trying to
warn people off of coming to the united
states well first off i want to
congratulate you on
getting your real estate license thank
you the jacket looks great
i knew you were going to come out for my
clothes
kamala's kamala's motto should be she's
not vp
she's why me because this is because
okay
technically she's now officially a
racist
right because how could her saying what
she said to guatemala
be construed any differently because if
anybody had said that six months ago or
eight months ago
because she viewed it through the filter
of race they would be
racist if you had a strong forceful
position on the border
which most republicans do then you were
a bad person you were racist so now she
gets into power
and she sounds like a republican she
should actually be denouncing herself
for her cold cold stance towards the
people down south
and it shows you how it also shows you
how um
the media responds and so now if you
criticize
kamala about her job you say she's not
up to the job then you're again
racist or you're sexist how and
however it was the democratic party that
threw her out was it december 2019
first like yeah she was the first one to
go with like three percent
and who did they choose instead of her a
really old white guy who knew
somebody in the clan so i don't know
what's going on here i think the world
has spoken
uh kamala harris is a racist uh
and the media had eviscerated people as
bigots
for saying the very same thing and it
makes me think maybe the media's playing
favorites dana
i don't know if that's the case i may
not have enough data on that but i think
they might
have not meant it when they were calling
everybody racist
that's true they might not have a little
disingenuous yes yes do you and if you
see anything like a four bedroom uh-huh
uh with a pool
if you could just like you know
one of those do you need a basement for
all of your ferrets i need a bit and the
other things that you do in the basement
okay i'll be looking into that you're
actually right this does look like a
real estate outfit
um okay geraldo you've cut you've been
in guatemala in the past
um you saw that they were at odds a
little bit about what the root cause is
do you think there was anything that the
biden administration put forth today
that would actually get to the root
cause
well first of all i am much more bullish
on migration
than most of the people in this building
i really believe that it is the uh
characteristic of robust growing
vibrant country that we take these
strong backs
we absorb them look at all the help
wanted signs there's an unmistakable
pull you or stay there you get two bucks
a day
come here you get 20 bucks an hour uh
you know so uh
in in terms of what's going on now and
the disorder and the dysfunction at the
border i think that is lamentable
and i do put the responsibility for that
on the biden administration
i i think that president trump was harsh
he was a bully he took the mexican
president lopez opened the door and
kind of slapped him around and said
we're going to put tariffs on you if you
don't
use the mexican army to intervene and
intercede and stop these folks from
taking the 2 000 mile trek across mexico
to get to our southern border
biden's message was much more mushy you
know
yeah calm comments great you know
immigration you know what i said to
start
my little segment here immigration is
good biden said
that's the wrong message for the
american president the american
president has to say stay home
apply get in line right and so forth and
as a result
of his mixed messaging i think you have
chaos now and you have
a tragedy being acted out in the arizona
desert colin harris also responded to
gop criticism take a listen to this
katie
on the issue of republicans political
attacks or criticism
or even concerns the reason i am here in
guatemala as my first trip
as vice president of the united states
is because this is one of our highest
priorities and i will continue to be
focused
on that kind of work as opposed to grand
gestures
okay so visiting the border where there
are a number of american citizens
affected by
this crisis is now some kind of grand
gesture
it's nice that the vice president is in
guatemala to figure out what the route
causes of this whatever they want to
come up with to make an excuse for their
own policy positions
you can talk a lot but if you don't have
policy positions to back up
and stop the flow coming north nothing
is going to change
and she talks about republican criticism
it's not just republicans it's
border state democrats like henry
cuellar for example who's the one who
first gave us all the
those photos of the crowded facilities
the ice facilities saying you need to do
something about this
just had the mayor of mcallen texas a
republican
win in that city when hillary clinton
won that city by 40 percent
it's an 85 percent hispanic population
there and this idea that they
they keep saying well on one hand we
don't want you to come
but on the other hand as the president
of mexico uh guatemala said
you know your policy is saying if you
let kids stay and families and parents
stay
then people are going to continue the
coyotes are going to benefit from that
that's a square peg and a round hole on
one hand you can't say
don't come but then have policies that
enable that and the final thing is
you know when you're dealing with
criminal mexican cartels
who are making 20 million dollars a day
of trafficking which these
politicians in guatemala are concerned
about and today
the vice president actually was being
protested today by locals saying stop
funding criminality you need a tough guy
like trump you need tough policies to
stop
cartels from profiting off of this human
crisis
and apparently the bite administration
has no interest in doing that
and taking it seriously and she's the
vice president of the united states not
of guatemala so maybe visiting a couple
of towns that are affected by this would
be nice but
it does make you wonder sean if the
grant
remember when all the democrats went and
did grand gestures at the border
during the campaign i mean i mean is
that what was happening i think during
you know child separation policy and
going down there and all that
but i also wanted to ask you this so
biden gives her this charge back
75 days ago okay and then she's waited
okay now
three days ago she got the assignment to
try to get the election bill
passed for the democrats and joe manchin
the senator from west virginia put a
stake in that over the weekend so
she's not batting a thousand she gets
the garbage can of all of joe biden's
priorities right she gets stuck with all
the garbage but
i think to katie's point i think it's
important to note that um
she's looking for the root causes of
what's going on in guatemala and the
northern triangle countries and
if you wonder what the root cause is
there's there's corruption
people want to get the heck out and the
borders open so
close our border and actually have
people stay in these countries the
innovators the
job creators um the entrepreneurs if
they stay there they'll force the
political change that's necessary but
if if we think that we're going to give
guatemala and the northern triangle
countries
billions of dollars and think that
tomorrow we're going to resolve their
problems we're not it's going to take
decades
and so we're going to keep the border
open for for 2 20 years and let people
come up and into the country i think we
as americans
have a right to say who comes in and who
doesn't it's not willy nilly who wants
to make the trek north over
you know 1500 miles and come into you
know
i think the case could be made that the
actual root cause is the problem that we
don't have a secure border
yeah but i don't i disagree i do want
the people
that take the risk because that's that
that usually agrees that usually is the
person
that now i would want him to do with
leadership but but they're making the
survival of the
they're usually 2 000 miles yeah the
innovators are the people that
we want to we want the innovators we
want the creators but i know
there's a lot of bad people coming up
across the board drug dealers
but they make it over the walls they
make it they fly they dig
they take boats the pros are not going
to be stopped but what happens
the wall stops juan and maria though
this is the
what happens to guatemala if those
people stay
nothing big vacuum cleaners suck up
all those billions of dollars it's going
to suck up that's good to be back in
studio or you can have a little
argument hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else